nous sommes le 17 octobre merci de nous
rejoindre pour une nouvelle édition du
78 lactu je vous propose de découvrir
dès à présent l'image du jour c'était à
Montini le Breton devant l'église
Saint-Quentin les sources à l'occasion
de la Journée mondiale de refus de la
misère une opération menée par ATD
carmonde afin de sensibiliser ce matin
sur les conditions des personnes en
difficulté ATD carmonde qui en a profité
aujourd'hui sur le plan national pour
dévoiler un livre blanc sur la
discrimination et la pauvreté rapport
remis au Président de l'Assemblée
nationale et au défenseurs des droits on
y découvre le résultat de testing qui
ont été menés et qui démontre par
exemple que de nombreux CV émanant de
personnes précaires sont ignoré ATD
carmonde demande que la discrimination
pour pauvreté soit inscrite au code
pénal dans le cadre des Rencontres de la
sécurité dans les ivelines une action de
sensibilité sensibilisation au danger de
la route été mené ce matin par la
ddsp78 à bord de véhiculle banalisé la
police a procédé à des contrôles de
conduites des chauffeurs de la société
skibus entre trappé la verrière le
reportage d'Olivier Maniscalco et d'éodi
moine donc là on voit bien que le
clignotant d'un côté est resté ça c'est
important de le garder et ensuite voilà
le clignotant qui va être
remis sur la la gauche pour pouvoir
quitter l'arrêt et
tourner le de police Stan est au zag
dans le véhicule banalisé qui suit
discrètement le bus 418 entre trappe et
la verrière et pour cause ce jeudi matin
il est là pour contrôler la conduite des
chauffeurs des lignes skibus dans le
cadre des actions de sensibilisation de
sécurité routière mise en place par la
DDSP 78 les policiers distribuent
ensuite des permis vert pour une
conduite excellente orange s'il constate
quelques écarts et rouge pour faute
grave on va vous remettre à permis vert
excellence on vous a suivi pendant un
certain temps et on a remarqué que vous
avez un comportement exemplaire et que
vous mettez les clignotants à chaque
fois donc c'est c'est
parfait et les collègues il font un peu
n'importe quoi chacun conduit à sa façon
mais voilà c'est comme ça je conduis
toujours comme ça donc je prends soin
des clients je freine pas trop fort les
cliotant le respect du code de la route
quoi de motard en civil procédait
également à des contrôles ce matin seul
des permis Verts ont été délivrés à une
dizaine de chauffeurs skibus par la DDSP
néanmoins ces bons résultats sont à
nuancer car les chauffeurs avaient été
prévenus que des contrôles seraient
opérés dans la matinée il est vrai que
c'est une première mais d'ors et déjà
nous avons pris donc des dates pour
justement le le perpétuer bien en aval
pardon lors d'autres journées mais là on
ira sur une journée complète et sans
avoir à prévenir les chauffeur aussi en
attendant une prochaine journée de
sensibilisation les policiers continuent
leur travail de prévention dans la
après-midi à bord des bus ils
accompagnent des collégiens pour les
mettre en garde sur l'incivilité dans
les transports en
commun l'invité de cette édition c'est
tarmel Dané bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes présidente de
l'association elles aussi dans les
Yvelines vous battez depuis 1992 pour la
parité en politique ces derniers mois il
y a eu quelques évolutions dans la loi
on va en parler notamment de ce texte
voté le 17 avril validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel dorén avant pour les
élections municipales le scrutin de
liste s'applique aussi aux communes de
1000 habitants et plus auparavant
c'était uniquement pour les communes de
plus de 3500 habitants concrètement
derrière ce ce jargon un petit peu de
d'organisation politique ça va changer
quoi bon alors d'abord merci de nous de
nous accueillir ça va changer ben que à
peu près au niveau de la France 6500
communes vont devoir présenter des
listes paritaires hein des listes avec
soit une femme un homme une femme un
homme soit un homme une femme un homme
une femme et que une fois la la liste
élu les exécutifs seront paritaires
alors dans les ivelines ça va concerner
en fait 60 communes et donc dans ces
communes dénavant on pourra avoir des
listes qui seront un homme une femme
comme vous l'avez dit ce sont pour la
l'anecdote hein ce sont des listes dites
shabadabada voilà forcément pour ceux
qui auront reconnu c'est une référence à
la musique du film un homme une femme de
Claude Lelouche alors avec ce nouveau
texte cette nouvelle donne vous allez
sensibiliser aussi vous allez organiser
des des réunions pour ne serait-ce que
apprendre aux femmes qu'elles peuvent
aussi être candidate tout simplement
absolument bah c'est un appel d'air pour
les femmes alors il y a aussi un petit
changement aussi pour les
intercommunalités puisque pour les
communes de plus de 1000 habitants la
liste des des délégués à
l'intercommunalité sera sur le bulletin
de vote elle sera également paritaire la
liste donc ça va entraîn c'est un appel
d'air également pour pour des femmes
dans les intercommunalités ce qui est
important puisque les intercommunalités
votent quand même à peu près 80 % des
investissements des communes voilà alors
euh oui au niveau national donc nous
organisons une opération qui s'appelle
donc euh 2000 2014 en avant les femmes
élu local une responsabilité une
richesse et donc cette action va être
décliner à peu près dans une vingtaine
de départements et donc dans les
ivelines alors dans les ivelines nous
organisons donc deux forums ce qui vont
se passer de matinées de samedi matin
l'un à mantelaville le 9 le 9 novembre
le samedi matin 9 novembre et un à
joirpontchartrin le samedi suivant le 16
novembre alors durant ces forums en fait
ça permet à des femmes candidates qui
hésitent hein à à se porter candidate de
rencontrer des femmes élues des maires
des maires adjoints il y aura même une
députée alors comment vous expliquez
aussi qu'il faille aussi aller à la
rencontre des femmes ça veut dire
qu'elle n'ose pas non plus aussi
franchir le pas de s'engager en
politique alors généralement quand il y
a une constitution de liste souvent on
va chercher les personnes aussi bien les
les femmes que les hommes les hommes
également mais les femmes plus elles
sont elles font moins le premier pas et
donc euh c'est le poid des des d'années
je sais pas alors ce que nous ce que
l'on cherche c'est que quand on vient
les chercher elles disent oui tout de
suite elles n'hésite pas et elles se
disent oh là là j'aurais pas le temps
est-ce que je suis compétente parce
qu'on fait toujours des procès
d'incompétence aux femmes hein est-ce
que je pourrais mener tout tout de front
en fait il faudra quand même qu'elle
réorganisent un petit peu leur temps et
qu'elles aient un soutien à la maison
pour partager un petit peu plus les
tâches voilà des choses comme ça donc
c'est un petit peu pour les pour les
booster et en plus on pense que le le
témoignage de femmes élues qui ont
réussi et qui ont eu un bonheur réel a
exercé leur mandat se transmet comme ça
par par des rencontres en fait elles
vont vraiment échanger c'est elles vont
pouvoir poser leurs questions hein et
elles vont pouvoir bénéficier de ces
témoignag de femmes qui ont trouvé que
le mandat était vraiment une une grande
richesse par ces femmes élu justement
ces femmes qui ont réussi à devenir
mères dans leurs différentes communes
notamment elles sont
nombreuses pour l'instant elles ne sont
que 14
% voilà donc oui en fait le véritable
problème qui reste encore bon il y a une
loi là qui a beaucoup amélioré les
choses mais le véritable problème reste
les femmes tête de liste ça c'est un
gros problème c'est là où je voulais
effectivement venir parce que il y a ces
listes qui permettent de de retrouver
une parité enfond de trouver une parité
sur les différentes listes pour autant
il faut des têtes de listes qui sont
appelé à devenir maire et à diriger la
commune et là c'est plus rare oui mais
alors bon le fait qu'il va y avoir quand
même un appel dans les petites communes
2000 à à 3500 habitants il y a des
femmes qui vont être maire adjoint avec
des postes importants donc elle pourra
être de futur maire quand même
éentuellement occuper ensuite cette
responsabilité en plus faut booster les
femmes à aller vers aussi les
intercommunalités parce que c'est là que
se prennent des grosses décisions
comment réagissent aussi les électeurs
parce qu'il y a la parité sur les listes
il y a éventuellement des des candidates
aussi tête de liste pour devenir devenir
maire est-ce que c'est c'est un frein
est-ce que les hommes votent aussi parce
que ça on peut pas l'imposer la parité
au moment du vote ah bah si les listes
c'est c'est un vote par liste donc c'est
un vote par liste mais tête de liste en
revanche et ensuite désignation est-ce
que c'est un pense que au niveau de la
société française il y a aucun frein
c'est au niveau du milieu politique
lui-même qui est un véritable milieu
encore mate et l'actualité vous donne
raison l'actualité vous donne forcément
raison puisque le 8 octobre dernier le
député UMP Philippe leuray a imité une
poule tand dit que s'exprimait l'élu
devienne Europe Écologie Les Verts
Véronique massonau comment vous avez
réagi à ça très mal j'imagine bah oui on
a réagi mal mais enfin pour une fois on
peut dire que la honte a changé de camp
parce qu'il y a eu une véritable il y a
eu une sanction ça été dans toute la
presse et il n'y a pas que pour lui
d'ailleurs parce qu'il y a des députés
paraî-il enfin c'est une de nos de nos
adhérentses d'Alsace qui nous a dit que
des députés d'Alsace qui ricanit à côté
de lui se sont retrouvés dans les pages
de la presse quotidienne régionale en
train de ricaner donc c'est aussi honte
à eux donc je pense que là les choses
vont commencer enfin à évoluer c'est un
événement anecdotique qui prêterait
presque à sourire parce qu'on se dit que
cette cette réaction est finalement
assez assez stupide mais est-ce que
c'est courant est-ce que c'est quotidien
est-ce que ça arrive régulièrement ce
genre de chos et que c'est c'est moins
médiatisé oui je pense oui enfin toutes
les femmes politiques qui ont réussi
vous vous donneront des anecdotes comme
cela je pense que le le le but dans ce
CASL c'est de d'essayer de mettre de
déstabiliser la personne parce que c'est
une femme on s'attaque au fait qu'elle
soit une femme on veut la
déstabiliser
pas fa mon qui domine c'est pas elle
est-ce qu'il y a des formations
politiques qui sont plus en retard que
d'autres sur ces questions de parité
d'égalité homme-femme parce que là on on
mentionnait un député UMP mais est-ce
que vous avez constaté depuis 1992 que
dans certaines formations politiques ce
soit la plus avancée la plus avancée ce
sont les vers puisque c'est dans leur
statut je pense que le PS a commence à
évoluer le Parti communiste je pense est
bien placé aussi bon voilà on peut pas
on peut parler de C formation là mais il
y a encore du travail c'est au partis
politiques de donner l'exemple et de
d'œuvrer au sein de leur de leur
formation de toute façon la parité ce
n'est pas uniquement en politique c'est
aussi dans la société au quotidien dans
les entreprises on va écouter à présent
une interview celle de Murielle pringer
elle est présidente d'entrepreneuriat au
féminin membre de la CGPME dans le
département des ivelines elle va nous
parler de la situation au sein des
entreprises la parité au travail là
aussi beaucoup d'efforts sont encore à
faire une interview réalisée par Claire
Cambier dans le cadre de la semaine de
sensibilisation à l'égalité homm-femm au
travail lancée par la ministre naja ro
Belkassem la loi est déjà là hé làas
elle est très rarement appliquée comme
on l'a vu seul 13 à 15 % des entreprises
l'appliquent donc on voit qu'il y a
vraiment un gros travail de fond à faire
mais comme disait pendant la conférence
il y a aussi un gros travail de fond à
faire sur la partie école sur la partie
éducation sur le fait de pouvoir oser et
savoir qu'on peut oser et on voit des
entreprises qui elles ont créé ont mis
en place de la mixité depuis quelques
années et ça marche plutôt bien et ça
plutôt permis de mettre un bon climat
social donc je pense qu'au contraire ça
peut nous permettre de nous sortir d'une
certaine crise on vient d'entendre une
réaction avec on espère une évolution à
venir dans les prochaines années vous
vous la constatez partout cette
inégalité ce manque de parité homm-femm
en entreprise aussi
bien sûr enfin ça va progresser mais ça
ça progresse lentement mais ça va venir
là je pense qu'il y a une une prise de
conscience maintenant et la prise de
conscience doit venir aussi des femmes
parce qu'elles pensent quand elles
arrivent au niveau de entreprise elles
sont jeunes elles disent l'égalité aucun
problème mais dès qu'elles vont avoir le
premier enfant là elles vont se rendre
compte que c'est là que les choses
commencent à se gâter merci Armel Dané
d'être venue sur le plateau présidente
es aussi Eveline la loi qui évolue sur
ces questions de parité notamment ce
sera perceptible dès les prochaines
élections municipales on en a parlé ce
soir merci à vous je vous remercie la
Semaine Bleue semaine consacrée aux
personnes âgées aura lieu du 21 au 27
octobre l'occasion de nous intéresser au
dispositif d'aide mis en place notamment
Lapp l'aide aux personnes âgées 55
millions d'euros c'est le budget annuel
de cette aide 4 l pour les
précisions selon l'INC en 2020 le
département des ivelines devrait être le
département le plus vieillissant de
l'île de France il faut donc s'y
préparer ces moyens ils sont de deux
natures d'abord et avant tout le
maintien à domicile le soutien à
domicile des personnes âgées parce que
ça répond à une attente et un souhait
des personnes âgées et des familles de
rester dans leur cadre qui est leur
cadre personnel familial qui est leur
leur repère leur identité et donc c'est
très important de les aider à rester à
domicile et puis il faut aussi
développer des places en établissement
spécialisés d'ici 2018 750 nouvelles
places d'accueil pour les personnes
âgées seront créées dont un
établissement à Montini le Bretonneux le
Conseil Général consacre 55 millions
d'euros rien que pour l' pas l'aide pour
les personnes âgées qu'ell soit à
domicile ou dans un établissement
hospitalier un dispositif qui depuis ce
mercredi est accessible via Internet
aujourd'hui pour instruire un dossier
sous forme papier il faut tout de même
compter en moyenne de
ça facilitera je pense la vie des
personnes âgées parce que ça va
permettre de diminuer le délai le délai
donc de de transmission des des demandes
ça va permettre également aux familles
plutôt que d'appeler le service Intel
qui repassait un autre service où on est
où on est mon dossier où on est ma
demande ils l'auront donc dev visu à
n'importe quelle heure du jour et la
nuit ils pourront effectivement
déterminer donc où on est leur dossier
donc la fluidité et ça va permettre
également donc nous de nous articuler
entre l'accès au droits des personnes
c'estàdire dossier administratif et
également le plan d'aide qui va être
réalisé par les coordinations
gérontologiques dans le département 5000
personnes bénéficient de Lapa à domicile
et 7000 dans les établissements
hospitaliers un futur centre de médecine
gériatrique va voir le jour à Plaisir la
première pierre vient d'être posée pour
l'été 2015 la construction de ce centre
de 144 lit et places accueillera les
patients de médecines geriatrique
polyvalente et psychi gérariatrique
cognitive en hospitalisation complète en
hospitalisation de jour et en
consultation pour plus de clarté je vous
propose ce reportage de yolen
Torz élu professionnel de la santé
chacun à leur tour il participe à la
pose de la première pierre du futur
centre de médecine gériatrique le
bâtiment constituera la trème partie de
l'hôpital gérontologique et
médico-social de plaisir Grignon il y
aura 144 lit à la fois du cours séjour
donc des des personnes âgées qui restent
assez peu de temps 20 30 jours et cetera
du soin de suite et radaptation
gériatrique et également des hôpitaux
plusfin des unités plus spécialisé vers
les troubles neurocognitif et ce c'est
un transfert des des lits que vous voyez
dans le bâtiment qui est derrière le
bâtiment qui est derrière sera
totalement ou partiellement désinfecté
les objectifs principaux du transfert
développer la partie consultation mais
aussi la partie technique avec
l'implantation d'un nouveau scanner pour
la ville de plaisir c'est aussi une
architecture plus
moderne c'est un pas vers l'avenir je
dirais ça va s'ouvrir en 2015 2015 c'est
demain on est déjà je veux dire aux
portes de
2014-25 c'est une vraie modernité au
centre au centre même de la ville de
plaisir on est vraiment privilégié par
rapport à ça
l'accueil ne serait-ce que du terrain
quand vous voyez c'est un grand parc
donc en plus les médecins rappelai la
qualité le confort la confiance qu'on
peut y attendre pour la ville de plaisir
c'est un plus Coutau de l'opération 28
millions d'euros financé par l'hôpital
de plaisir et par des crédits de
l'agence régionale de santé le bâtiment
sera livré dans 2
ans du sport dans le cadre d'une tournée
à travers la France l'équipe junior de
taendo de la ville de moujou en Coré du
Sud s produit àtin le Bretonneux équipe
de référence à travers le monde elle a
démontré son talent au gymnase Pierre
decoubertin en présence du club local
qui enseigne cette discipline le TKD
78 Montini le Bretonneux et joue en
Corée du Sud réunie derrière la bannière
du taekwendo grâce aux efforts d'un club
sportif le TKD 78 implanté sur C1 en
Yveline depuis plus de 15 ans pour C les
7 union une démonstration de l'équipe
junior de la ville coréenne s'est
déroulé jeudi soir 31 jeunes de 8 à 18
ans ont démontré toute leur
maîtrise c'est pas la même culture c'est
pas la même éducation parce que c'est
pas si je peux dire ça comme ça c'est
pas les même centre d'intérêt je pense
que là il y a beaucoup de je dirais de
le code de l'honneur il ne faut pas
décevoir et cetera et cetera donc il
donn leur meilleur pour pas décevoir
quoi tout simplement ils sont vraiment
synchronisés et ça c'est quand même une
difficulté assez complexe dès l'instant
où on est beaucoup je dirais à produire
la démonstration on a rien à leur envier
si nos élèves se préparent correctement
il y a AUC aucun problème pour qu'ils
arrivent à un niveau comme ça après
c'est juste une question
d'investissement bien sûr on va
s'appuyer sur cette démonstration pour
faire avancer no petit bien
sûr le district de moujou appelé à
prendre encore plus d'importance dans le
monde du taendo avec l'ouverture l'an
prochain d'un centre international
d'éducation de recherche et de formation
autour de la
discipline le parc international de
taekwendo est porté par le gouvernement
coréen pas uniquement par Muju et il
sera impressionnant avec 2000 m car le
corps l'intellect et l'esprit seront à
l'honneur et la démonstration a doute
donner l'envie aux quelques 320
adhérents du TKD 78 et d'effectuer un
pèlerinage dans cette capitale du
taekwendo fin de ce journal je vous
retrouve demain vendredi 18h nous ferons
notamment un retour sur cette opération
de contrôle de conduite des chauffeurs
de la société de bus skibus mené par les
forces de l'ordre c'était aujourd'hui
nous reviendrons aussi sur la journée du
don de ce jeudi et la participation de
la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance Maladie à
Versailles puis bien sûr toute
l'actualité
du jour je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur TV fil et avec une nouvelle
édition ce soir de filco magazine
économique de la rédaction présenté par
Claire camb bonne
soirée